we have to train the astronauts how to
use the cameras and light scenes aboard
the space station and they're really
good students there are quick studies
and pick it up very quickly but
occasionally they need to contact us on
earth once they're in orbit as to how to
do something or they have a question and
usually when they do that they call down
to earth to Mission Control and then
Mission Control contacts us with the
question and so on and so forth after
we'd finish this mission I had gone to
stay with a friend just to rest for a
couple of days and my cell phone rang at
six in the morning and I thought who on
earth would call me on my cell phone at
six in the morning I was really cranky
and I kind of barked hello into the
phone and at the other end it said hi
this is Jim Voss I'm calling from the
space station well I drop the phone I
couldn't imagine I thought this was
somebody playing a joke but no it was
real he wanted my advice about how to
set up in light a particular scene that
he'd been thinking very hard about and
it was not an easy scene to shoot it was
the descent down into the Soyuz
spacecraft that they were all going to
enter they had grown some plants up
there this was not expected so it wasn't
really on my short list we talked about
how best to shoot those so they'd make
good 3d and that turned out to be
enormously successful and then I always
tell an astronaut crew if an alien comes
up and puts his face in the window
obviously you're going to shoot that
even if it's not on my scene list please
do shoot it so what happened was this
shot
you
so I have three other calls they were
always at five or six in the morning
always when I was in bed and I was lying
there talking to the space station
you